hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well earlier in the
Mona Logan for example in chapter 32
handsome has talked about parallels
between the rational human mind and the
divine if you want the divine mind just
the divine itself the rational human
mind is able to make an image of itself
for itself it does so what ever thinks
about itself and its thereby similar to
although actually more patterned after
rather than you know providing the
pattern for of the Divine Word which it
turns out to the second person of the
Trinity it turns out to be this this
whole economy that's going on Ansem is
going to follow out some of those ideas
in chapter is 66 and 67 which is what
we're talking about here but now the
framework is no longer in terms of you
know trying to just draw a short little
parallel like that it's rather than we
can use the human mind which is what
we're equipped with right to understand
at least to some degree the divine and
this arises in the context of us
question about the divine is being an
affable but being approachable even
rationally through the use of images so
the question then that he begins with it
in chapter 66 is well what is the best
image to use should we say look at
creation and use that to understand God
or should we perhaps as good
augustinians look within and think about
our rational nature so in some says that
in order to better understand God it's
going to be a more useful strategy to
look to what is more like God right
don't we look at adams you were even god
particle if you like look at things that
we think have more in common you could
say well what what actually participates
more in the divine attributes and so
what is it he says it's certain that one
comes closer to knowing him through the
head which is nearer to him because
there's more like him what a mom created
days is shown to be more like him must
be more excellent by nature so what is
more excellent by nature we've talked
about this already with the degrees of
being rational nature right so he says
because of its greater likeness such a
thing gives more help to the
investigating mind and coming closer to
the Supreme Truth and because of its
more excellent creative essence it more
fully teaches what that might want to
believe about the creative so if we pick
the better object we're going to make
more progress in understanding to define
well the rational mind is the is the
only creature that rises up yeah seeks
god that actually asked questions about
God I mean you could say well maybe the
birds and the bees are you know part of
some divine plan but they don't think to
themselves Zarah God isn't there a gap
what is God like you know these go and
do
their thing right so the insult says
it's evident just as the rational mind
is the only thing among all creatures
they can rise up to seek him it's no
less true that the rational mind is the
only thing notice what he says the only
thing through which the mind itself can
best make progress in fighting it he's
not saying it's the only thing that we
can make any progress but if we want the
best strategy for understanding God we
should look to the rational mind now he
also tells us something else about this
and this is very very interesting this
should make us think about you know sort
of the turn within you know for example
the Cartesian Co chicho and the notion
that by looking within we're going to
understand things in song says that
self-knowledge and not just self
knowledge about you know that your body
but self-knowledge primarily about your
mind it is going to be very productive
so he says what did it what is more
obvious than this the more diligently
the rational mind tries to come to know
itself the more efficaciously it rises
up to know yeah and the more and a glass
to look upon itself the more it falls
away from seeing an implication here is
that inadequate ways of understanding
yourself or you might say less than
truthful ways of trying to understand
yourself are actually going to be
impediments not only is understanding
oneself but to understanding God insofar
as we're not entirely what we want to be
we are the obstacles standing in the way
of understanding the divine in chapter
60 70 is going to bring this home and he
says what the mind is as we can call it
a mirror for itself that's one way to
think about it it's reflexive the mind
is able to think about itself right the
body can can touch itself but the body
can't think about itself in the way that
the
I can write the mind you move the body
body of course can confess with the mind
I suppose but the mind has this
reflexivity running through itself to
through its very core Anselm talks about
having an image of what it is unable to
to see actually let me read that phrase
because it's so nice he says the mind is
said to be a mirror for itself in which
it might see if I may put it that way
the image of him who it cannot see face
to face for is the mind alone among all
created things and then he talks about
these three key activities let's call
them or functions of the mind memory
remembering understanding intellect and
love it amor love right those correspond
as we've seen before to the three
persons of the Trinity the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit they're in an
economy of all of that the human mind
actually does all of that with itself or
at least it can do that with itself it
can remember itself and as a matter of
fact it does so a lot of the time
without us really being all that
conscious of it it can understand itself
it could reason with itself it can make
sense of things it can love itself as a
matter of fact again I at least on some
level it probably does that without us
even thinking of that so he says if the
mind alone among all created things can
remember and understand love itself I do
not see why one would deny that there is
in it in true image of that essence who
through his memory and understanding and
love constitutes an ineffable
Trinity so we're not this isn't a
concept of the divine as such but by
reflecting upon what it is that our mind
actually does we're able to have an
image of the workings of the Trinity
pretty uh you know you might say
optimistic notions on the ants on
spartan compares to another christian
theologians and philosophers so it says
or certainly it proves itself to be more
truly his image by the fact that it can
remember understand and love him so not
only does it have these operations in
relation to itself it can also direct
those operations to the divine substance
as well that sets up this interesting
set of relations within the human mind
and down here on paper the product of
the human mind so he says by that which
is that point which it is greater and
more like him is that by which it is
more recognized as a truer image of him
so he says it's altogether impossible to
think the rational creature was
naturally given anything so preeminent
and so much like the supreme wisdom as
its ability to remember and understand
of love that which is the best and grace
of all things no creature was endowed
with anything else that thus displays an
image of the Creator this is distinct to
rational beings they are able by virtue
of this reflex in relationship to grasp
the divine in ways that non rational
beings cannot and they can grasp
themselves in relation to the divine as
well so again this is this is still
working with images this is not
revealing what the divine is in its an
equable mysterious incomprehensible self
but it's getting about as close as we
human beings can get to it according to
Ansel